[Music]
foreign
did you know that there were two other
American Godzillas that did not make it
to the big screen of course we know
about the most of us titanus Gojira and
the 1998 tristarzilla along with its
animated version and the Hannah Barbera
cartoon but there were two others that
were unmade we will take a look at these
two Godzillas that never got to see the
light of day although their designs and
storyline have been written so we will
bring them to justice
the first one here is Godzilla king of
the monsters in 3D and was initially
planned to be a movie in the 1980s the
new design of Godzilla was a blend of
the classic Godzilla and a Tyrannosaurus
Rex the plan for special effects
included the use of Miniatures and
stop-motion animation they had also
finalized on a storyline which goes as
follows
so in a distant land a meteorite
collides with a defense satellite
triggering a nuclear massage launch and
explored in the South Pacific deep
beneath the ocean flow a slumbering
giant reptilian creature awakens across
the ocean a Japanese fishing vessel
mysteriously reappears in San Francisco
carrying a preserved trilobite a daring
journalist named Dana uncovers a
Survivor who utters The Haunting word
Gojira before dying Dana then seeks the
expertise of a paleobiologist named
Gerald who examines the trilobite but
meanwhile on Otto Island an American
Special Forces Squad encounters a
colossal reptilian monster leaving
Devastation in its wake
Gerald theorizes that the creature is a
dinosaur but the military dismisses his
ideas speculating that it may be
extraterrestrial in origin as
researchers transport the creature's
lifeless Offspring known as baby
Godzilla for studying Gerald names the
creature Godzilla based on Ancient
Japanese dragon myth along the
California coast the adult Godzilla
emerges destroying an old Derrick and a
tank as well Along by radiation
poisoning among those who interacted
with baby Godzilla Gerald realizes that
the baby is a living Atomic Reactor with
regenerative abilities despite his
warnings the military ignores him
Khrushchev a Soviet seizes Kevin
demanding the return of the missiles
which were lost to the Americans Kevin
escapes just as Godzilla rises from the
depths of San Francisco Bay the
military's attacks prove futile
provoking Godzilla's devastating Rampage
determined to save their City Daxton
Gerald and Dana Hatch a plan they use a
recording of baby Godzilla to lure
Godzilla away from the city intending to
eliminate it with the Russian missiles
Godzilla then discovers the lifeless
baby Godzilla in a warehouse releasing a
mournful Roar on Alcatraz Island Gerald
and Dana activate baby Godzilla's
recording catching Godzilla's attention
Daxton retrieved the remaining missile
and bought a high-tech battle helicopter
called scorpion 78 as they take flight
Kevin replaces the Fallen co-pilot
Daxton with a heavy heart guides the
helicopter while Kevin reluctantly fires
the missile into Godzilla's throats
ultimately ending the creature's Reign
Kevin tumbles from the helicopter but is
saved by Godzilla in the last moment
cheerfully he Witnesses Godzilla's final
breath
so that's the first canceled movie the
second one is the 1994 unmade Godzilla
vs Griffin the Godzilla here is more
upright and is greenish in coloration it
is more akin to the Toho variants while
the 1983 is more in the lines of azilla
posture dinosaur hybrid the Godzilla
design is largely similar to Hasty
Godzilla design only featuring a more
reptilian appearance with an alligator
like skin muscular arms for combat and
with slit pupils for the eyes during the
production of the movie Touhou sent
concept art for Godzilla from Godzilla
vs King Ghidorah as a reference in
designing the new king of the Masters
and also they finished the storyline and
it goes as follows
in the icy waters of the coast of Alaska
a ship was retrieving a Soviet Union's
dumb Reactor Core which triggers a
devastating explosion releasing a
mysterious substance resembling blood a
scientist named Keith investigates the
site where he and his team accidentally
awakened Godzilla who goes on a
destructive Rampage 12 years later
cryptozoologist Aaron Watt and Mary
kenoshita interviews a fisherman who
reveals the drawings of Godzilla
battling another monster they are
apprehended by the military police
meanwhile a biometallic media hits
Kentucky in the United States spawning
deadly creatures from it a person named
Jill now the director of a top secret
project joins forces with Vault to
locate Godzilla as strange events unfold
Godzilla resurface and heads towards San
Francisco again with the belief that
Godzilla is a living nuclear reactor
Vaught advices against the use of
nuclear weapons instead they use a
tranquilizer to subdue Godzilla the
military transports the unconscious
Godzilla to a facility in Massachusetts
however kenoshita succumbs to a
mysterious infection and reveals that an
ancient force is manipulating events in
Kentucky the creature evolves into the
Griffin Vaught and a local storekeeper
explore the lake and then encounters the
Monstrous Griffin meanwhile Godzilla
awakens and heads to confront the
Griffin in New York Jill attempts to
save her daughter during the chaos and
then the Griffin and Godzilla engage in
a fierce combat but Godzilla emerges
Victorious Jill then reconciles with
Godzilla and watches as he returns to
the Sea where the military Retreats
their attack and they leave him in peace
so those are the two Godzillas that we
never got to see but we wish we had this
would be the first American Godzillas in
the movie screens but unfortunately that
didn't happen unfortunately we got Zella
well almost fortunately and definitely
fortunately we got to see most of us
titanos Gojira so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
and most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates or new videos here on
this channel take care fam